now as we speak kenosha wisconsin is
bracing for today's closing arguments in
the kyle rittenhouse murder trial the
18-year-old from illinois claims he
acted in self-defense when he killed two
people and wounded a third last year
during protests over the police shooting
of jacob blake the wisconsin governor
has activated about 500 national guard
troops to help respond to any protest of
the verdict nancy chen is in kenosha
nancy good morning
nate good morning to you we spoke with
kyle rittenhouse's mother wendy over the
weekend she says her son only came to
kenosha to help that night despite the
fact that two people are now dead
kyle
told his side of the story and it was
the truth wendy rittenhouse is defending
her son kyle's actions on august 25 2020
when he traveled to kenosha to as he
says protect people's property but
during the tense night of protests
rittenhouse armed with an ar-15 style
weapon shot three people killing two of
them
kyle's nature is to help people so in
talking to him he does regret going that
night now yeah he does
but the prosecutor painted a different
picture the defendant fled
the scene
of the dead body of joseph rosenbaum
without stopping to offer any aid
whatsoever rittenhouse faces six charges
the most serious being intentional
homicide the jury heard from more than
30 witnesses over eight days about what
happened that night i
thought that the defendant was
an active shooter one of the most
dramatic moments was rittenhouse himself
describing what happened it was
what was going on in your mind as as you
saw him
scared overwhelmed frightened
i didn't want to see my son like that on
friday the judge indicated the jury will
likely be able to consider lesser
charges in the case the more charges the
more chance of conviction cbs news legal
analyst ricky clement the upside for a
defendant in the case of lesser included
offenses is that if there is a
conviction of a lesser included defense
the defendant would face a much lesser
punishment
18 jurors have heard this case today 12
will be randomly selected to decide the
verdict and because this is a
complicated trial that verdict could
take a while but if convicted of the
most serious charges right house could
face life in prison gale
jurors have a big responsibility today
thank you very much nancy